next week marks 75 years since the
Japanese attack on Pearl Harbor now
comes the first memoir of that day from
the perspective of a survivor who was
aboard the USS Arizona in all the
gallant men Donald Stratton writes about
being on the battleship when it exploded
and sank John Blackstone shares this
incredible story of survival
the battleship Arizona graces the back
of Donald Stratton's classic truck now
at 94 he points out the anti-aircraft
gun right there where as a 19 year old
he fought the Japanese sneak attack on
Pearl Harbor December 7th 1941 in less
than two hours American naval power in
the Pacific has been paralyzed some of
the pilots waved a distance world they
were waving at you while they issued
eyes and we were firing at him but we
could see our bursts in the sky and they
were away short the Arizona was one of
eight battleships under unrelenting
Japanese air strikes as seen on the
Smithsonian Channel series The Lost
Tapes a single lucky hit was responsible
for the disaster that befell the Arizona
just a fireball about six or eight
hundred feet in there and that just
engulfed us area I was like burning over
60% of my body we were just actually
burning alive
Randy Stratton is Don's son some of his
scars you can see some you can some
he'll never get over his whole life any
noise even to this day the phone goes
off he jumps through the ceiling because
of that bomb going off dense black smoke
billowed to the sky as the massive
control tower began to keel over for
nearly 75 years Stratton said little
about how he survived as more than 1100
others on the Arizona perish but he has
finally written two memoir all the
gallant men it reveals things even Velma
his wife of almost 67 years had never
heard when I read the book I cried he
really never talked about it they never
told me his story about anything about
what happened of the explosion Stratton
writes
the flames found us burning off our
clothes our hair our skin men stumbled
around in the deck like human torches
each collapsing into a flaming pile of
flesh a makeup artist re-creation of his
injuries is hard to look at how do you
go on fighting or trying to survive with
that amount of pain well it's just
self-preservation I just pull the skin
off harm from turning it down because
he's in the way and then you pulled the
skin off your arms well I was burned and
we're just hanging down there with the
flames below him and using badly burned
hands he somehow pulled himself along a
rope about 80 feet to safety on another
ship you were coming across that rope
the Japanese are still strafing oh yeah
they're still bombing and trip and
everything yeah recovery meant months of
searing pain and surgeries when doctors
wanted to amputate his limbs Stratton
refused did you think you're gonna make
it I don't think I ever entered my mind
that I wouldn't and he wouldn't be kept
away from the fight
little more than a year after Pearl
Harbor he re-enlisted and fought in the
Pacific did you think you had a score to
settle
thought about a little revenge but we
had a job to do over the years he has
returned again and again to the Arizona
Memorial that's very sad that's a very
sacred place I lost so many shipmates
that day it's just like going back and
living him all over again
on the 60th anniversary Japanese pilots
who attacked Pearl Harbor came in peace
and were greeted with friendship by many
American veterans have you managed to
forgive Japan let's put it this way
eleven hundred and sixty-seven men out
there on that Arizona's sure as hell
wouldn't shake hands with them so I'm
not going to do it next week on the 75th
anniversary he'll return with his whole
family including great-grandchildren
knowing that probably it will be the
last time and that's hard but the
Stratton family vows never to forget
like granddaughter Nicky each wears a
locket
holding a fragment of the USS Arizona
to constantly remind us where my
grandfather came from the Arizona is in
our blood quite literally in our blood
for most who visit the Arizona Memorial
now this sacred place is part of distant
history but it's not distant at all for
Donald Stratton as he writes in all the
gallant men I had lost a part of myself
in the ruins of that ship and a big part
of my family in the men who died there a
part of myself that now would be forever
and tubed with them for CBS this morning
John Blackstone Colorado screams oh my
this is the most incredible story is in
the perfect title isn't it norm for to
describe mr. Stratton and his people so
I'm reading here Don's right he's he's
one of only five survivors of the USS
Arizona still alive today and he also
holds the distinction of having served
as both the first and the last battles
of World War two I love that his wife
and he are together and that even she's
learning something and what a gift and a
blessing it is for us that he's sharing
the story with us everyone should know
the story of Donald Stratton right
gallant man indeed thank you John
Blackstone for that great story thank
you all right all Stretton yeah I know
yes yeah for writing that is right
that's right